[Music]
on this Tuesday night multiplying calls
to investigate foreign meddling
governments should air on the side of
transparency and how Australia's
national security Chief defines the
threat there are senior people in this
country who appear to believe that
Espionage and foreign interference is no
big deal logging off Tick-Tock the
Privacy fears piling up and the
politicians ditching the app a Class Act
who broke barriers I am the teacher I am
Mrs Burgers the story of Millie Burgess
one of Canada's first black Educators
and Ross Lord a global national original
riding off into retirement we're not
going to hang around here much longer
foreign
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin tonight with calls for greater
transparency about the nature of the
threat from foreign interference in
Canada's Democratic process the Globe
and Mail is reporting that China appears
to have targeted Justin Trudeau after he
became leader of the Liberals in 2013.
an anonymous National Security Source
told the newspaper the Chinese
government made a one million dollar
donation to The Pierre Elliott Trudeau
foundation in 2015 it alleges the money
was funneled through a Chinese
billionaire who was assured the Chinese
government would reimburse him for the
entire amount both Global News and the
Globe and Mail have reported allegations
China covertly supported candidates most
of them liberals in the 2019 and 2021
elections and there is some breaking
news from Ottawa our bureau chief
Mercedes Stevenson is with me Mercedes
another report into foreign interference
just released what does it conclude
Oh Donna this is the much vaunted report
the Prime Minister Trudeau and his
cabinet have been pointing to put
together by senior public servants uh
that would assess whether or not there
was foreign interference that affected
the outcome of the 2021 election what
this report concludes is that while
there were efforts at foreign
interference they were not sufficient to
meet the threshold for public
notification it says that Canada was
still able to hold a free and fair
election even though it did detect uh
some concerns about foreign interference
but there's two key things to keep in
mind here one is that it only looked at
the actual writ drop period though that
actual time period that the election
takes place and a lot of the experts are
saying the actual interference happens
in the nomination process which is
before the general election and the
panel didn't have a mandate to look into
that the second part is that Morris
Rosenberg a very well respected retired
bureaucrat LED this panel however he
also used to be the CEO of the Trudeau
foundation and that is something that
the position has already seized on so
there are much more questions to come
another day of intense scrutiny for the
liberal government about who knew what
when when it comes to beijing's attempts
to interfere in Canadian democracy
foreign interference represents a
serious threat to our institutions well
sources say the government is
increasingly focused on how to deal with
China's meddling critics say prime
minister Justin Trudeau and his cabinet
have been more interested in plugging
leaks than plugging holes in Canada's
defenses Security Experts have long
called for a foreign agent's registry
like Australia's or a foreign
interference Bill to be tabled as the UK
has done but Public Safety Minister
Marco Mendicino is not budging on
specific commitments or calls for an
inquiry delivering the same lines that
he's used for weeks on Tuesday in
Halifax we have put in place exactly the
mechanisms and the tools that we need to
mitigate against the threats Senator Ian
shugart is the country's former top
bureaucrat he says it's time for the
government to be be more open about the
threats Canada is facing and how the
government has handled them governments
should air on the side of transparency
because the public needs that
reassurance and as things get more
complicated
there may be greater need for that
reassurance former privy Council clerk
Michael wernick says there is no Silver
Bullet but there are immediately
available steps the government should
take right now to make it harder to
interfere in Canadian democracy why not
fast forward and start on the
legislation now start working on Cyber
defenses start working on disinformation
and and bulk up our defenses we don't
need the inquiry to to start on that
Mercedes we're going to come back to you
in just a moment as you pointed out
we're not the only country dealing with
this members of the so-called five eyes
Canada the U.S the UK New Zealand and
Australia are all grappling with foreign
interference that Alliance has an
intelligence sharing agreement and last
week the head of Australia's security
intelligence organization late without
the threat from hostile foreign
intelligence services not just China in
some pretty Stark terms here's part of
his speech
The Challenge from Espionage and foreign
interference
and I'm not convinced as a nation we
fully appreciate the damage it afflicts
on Australia's security democracy
sovereignty economy and social fabric
I'm concerned there are senior people in
this country who appear to believe that
Espionage and foreign interference is no
big deal it's something that can be
tolerated or somehow ignored or safely
managed
it goes on to say a lot more about the
exact nature of the threat Mercedes why
don't we see a similar level of
transparency here in Canada
well there is a growing course of voices
Donna that say that that's what's
necessary in order to deal with concerns
that Canadians have about the
information we're getting that
everything was was okay in these
elections the reinsurances from public
officials and that we're not actually
hearing the details of of what the
allegations are and what happened now In
fairness a lot of This is highly
classified information that can't be
released in public however as we just
saw there is a way to do it that doesn't
release that information and yesterday
it didn't seem like there was a lot of
an appetite for Mr Trudeau from that he
kind of took a shot at csis the
government has not been happy with the
leaks that have been coming out of that
organization but they show no signs of
stopping and when you speak to the
sources in these cases our Sam Cooper
has said a lot of the reason for the
leaks is that they are simply frustrated
with the government failing to act so
until there's more information there
might just be more leaks
Mercedes Stevenson in Ottawa thanks
Alberta has tabled a big spending budget
made possible by Soaring oil and gas
prices the timing couldn't be better for
the government of Premier Danielle Smith
who faces a provincial election in May
as Heather urich's West explains cash
promises though may not carry that much
weight with voters tremendous honor
today to rise in the house and present
budget 2023 Alberta is spending money
and in an election year it has plenty of
cash to spend predicting an oil price of
79 a barrel the province is projecting
70.7 billion dollars in Revenue next
year with plans to spend nearly 67
billion up 6.2 billion from Jason
kenney's last budget one year ago when
Alberta over the last three years we did
the heavy lifting fiscally we got our
fiscal house in order we're running a
surplus thanks to a very high energy
prices a very significant Surplus in the
current fiscal year Global oil prices
mean Alberta has seen the biggest
turnaround and Fortunes in Canadian
history going from a projected deficit
of 18.2 billion dollars in 2021 to a
budget forecast Surplus this year of
10.4 billion next year the province is
projecting another surplus of two point
0.4 billion
this year's United conservative
government is promising historic
increases for Health Care education and
post-secondary schools while promising
to beef up the province's rainy day fund
to 20 billion by the end of next year
this is a fraudulent budget designed to
buy votes ahead of the election and then
spring the costs on albertans after the
polls have closed still Alberta remains
reliant on what's never been reliable
energy revenues that are set to drop as
early as next year by then though
albertans will have already been to the
polls Donna Heather urich's West at the
legislature in Edmonton thinks it was
budget day in BC too the NDP government
there projecting a more than four
billion dollar deficit in a budget
packed with new spending aimed at health
care and affordability BC is dedicating
more than 6.4 billion dollars over three
years for health care including 1
billion in new funding for mental health
and addictions 4.5 billion dollars will
go to a suite of affordability measures
over the next three years those will
include a long promised renters rebate
expanded carbon tax and Child Benefits
plus hikes to social assistance and the
province will also introduce free
prescription contraception for BC
residents starting in April a Canadian
first
multiple provinces have just banned
Tick-Tock on government devices coming
up how some federal politicians are now
ditching the app too
Tick Tock has about 8 million users
across Canada the majority of them young
people it is no wonder politicians have
been eager to use the video sharing
platform to connect to that demographic
though as David Aiken reports that is
changing fast hit it get it get it NDP
leader jugmeat Singh easily led the way
among Canada's politicians when it came
to the social media app tick tock
Singh was a prolific and popular user
with 880 000 followers he mixed in
videos featuring wife and daughter
with political messages including Pierre
poliev just voted against Dental Care
conservative leader Pierre pauliev also
had a pretty good Tick-Tock game he had
230 000 users but pauliev this week shut
down his account and Singh put his on
pause those decisions followed a
government of Canada ban on the use of
The Tick Tock app on any
government-issued phone this is yet
another demonstration of the
government's vigilance when it comes to
any potential threats that may be posed
by Foreign interference or any other
risks to our cyber platforms and our
critical infrastructure some provinces
quickly followed the federal lead
Banning Tick Tock others are thinking
about it their moves come on the heels
of governments throughout the Western
world including the European commission
and the United States all worried that
China's part ownership in the company
that runs Tick Tock is too much of a
cyber security risk China though says
the U.S and others are overreacting
we firmly oppose the U.S side's wrong
approach of overstretching the concept
of National Security a Chinese
government spokesperson said Tuesday
experts are now calling on governments
to educate young people who make up the
vast majority of tick tock users about
the potential risks to privacy and
security while using the app Donna David
Aiken in Ottawa thanks
passion and perseverance ahead one of
Canada's first black teachers reflects
on her trailblazing career
as Black History Month comes to a close
we are taking a look at the life of a
remarkable educator Millie Burgess
started her teaching career in Toronto
back in 1957. she was the first black
teacher in Ontario and she went on to
educate and Inspire generations of
students Mike girlay has her story
two months shy of her 100th birthday
Millie Burgess still clearly remembers
the day she decided to become a teacher
she was five years old living in Bermuda
at the time she practiced teaching on
her eight siblings and loved it so much
she eventually was offered a scholarship
to Teachers College in Toronto when I
was coming people kept saying to me you
sure you want to go to Canada that's a
white country
yes and I said oh I said well what
difference does that make it was 10
years after Jackie Robinson had broken
the color barrier in baseball and Millie
decided to take a similar approach to
potential prejudices she'd stand up for
herself but try to educate her critics
she also fully recognized that this was
not Bermuda this was not a place where
the majority population looked like her
and I think for her she knew that there
were adjustments that were just part of
being in this country the Ontario Black
History Society believes that when
Millie took her first teaching job in
1957 at Ogden public school she became
the first black teacher in the
province's history
and she had the fortitude to see it
through like the time she had this
exchange with a parent he said I brought
my son
to school for the first time he said but
where is the teacher
so I said I am the teacher I'm Mrs
Burgess the teacher he said don't you
have a white teacher here
I said I'm sorry but I am the teacher
for this class
so I said if you have any problems go
see the principal at the office that she
says was the exception she became
friends with many of the parents of the
kids she taught how many years did you
teach 25 25 years 25.
you had you had to leave it 25 I begged
them to let me stay another year and
they wouldn't let me she was passionate
about her career most Pioneers are
microwave Global News Toronto
next the stories that stick with you
after 39 years of reporting
[Music]
our final note tonight is about one of
our own our Atlantic correspondent Ross
Lorde is retiring Ross was one of the
originals he's been with global national
since it first went on the air here's a
look at just a sliver of the many
stories he's covered
if they're concerned about their image
being tarnished by going from a delicacy
to a fast food item they're not
commenting he has a way with words and
Away with people that never change no
matter what story he covered
as you're the terrorist attack the 911
Terror attacks happened just after
global national first went on the air in
2001. commercial jetliners from all over
the world descended on Halifax
as fear and grief spread Ross told
Survivor stories with dignity and Grace
as he did with every tragedy that
unfolded on his watch it provides little
consolation for the families of 15 coal
miners trapped in the cold dark ground
the preserver has a crew of 150 people
whose lives might never be the same
after spending a full week at the scene
of one of the worst plane crashes in
Canadian history a 12-passenger van
demolished near Bathurst New Brunswick
nearly an entire High School boys
basketball team wiped out instantly
Moncton has had its problems in recent
years but nothing like this using a
semi-automatic rifle to kill three
mounties and injure two others a crime
crown and defense call one of the worst
in Canadian history the more Nova
scotians learn about the shooter's
movements the more grateful some are
that they left the areas he visited just
in time but the snow is only part of the
problem storms have a way of chasing
Ross he's probably covered more than any
of our reporters the blizzard warning
thing came one day ahead of the actual
storm the new federal government is
promising to bring back local weather
service to Newfoundland communities like
Buena Vista Venezuela roads like this
one are closed and the river continues
to rise so does the number of people
moving to safety here in New Brunswick
even though it's not as intense as one
Earl is actually three times as large
we're not going to hang around here much
longer just in case anything more is
brought down during Porter Bass today
there is incremental progress in
cleaning up some of this debris but
they're still sizing up the immense
recovery that lies ahead he showcased
the wonders of Atlantic Canada and the
more icebergs we see here in Northern
Newfoundland the more questions arise
about why when you're standing this
close the biggest impression is the
smell an estimated 80 tons of decaying
blubber and pursued those in power Arya
from holding politicians to account to
bringing us the stories of Politics as
political pressure grows on the
government so does economic pressure on
the workers the upcoming vote has
injected something into this community
that never existed before tension
he's covered International upheaval
including the war in Afghanistan
Iraq's fire is the troubling symbol of a
change in tactic by Afghanistan
insurgents this is the fourth attack on
the Kandahar Airfield in recent weeks by
establishing an extra base in
Afghanistan the Canadian military is
hoping it will have a greater presence
in this country Canada hasn't lost so
many soldiers in a combat role in such a
short period of time since the Korean
War and Haiti after the devastating 2010
earthquake as soon as the dust cloud
settles scroungers scramble in to try to
retrieve anything that might be worth
value to them and their families at this
Camp there are thirty thousand people
living in squalor afraid that at any
moment they or their children will catch
a disease reporting on the darkness of
human tragedy but always finding some
light gander is part of 9 11 history is
fairly well known by now but what really
impresses us and Strikes us this time is
the lasting connections between the
stranded passengers and those who
console them in their time of Crisis it
was hard to know what to expect from a
makeshift campaign that lasted only one
week but now it's worked there are 60
tons of food sitting in this warehouse
and always seeking new insights with
intelligence Grace and humor now a final
wish that might really test your holiday
spirit it's about the hockey team that
millions of us have been supporting for
longer than we care to mention yes this
team true they've been scuffling this
season firing the coach and everything
but isn't there a chance even a small
chance they could come back
I don't know maybe they win the Stanley
Cup
isn't 53 years of failure enough
well they don't call it wishful thinking
for nothing okay
[Laughter]
Buzz is with me now from Halifax Ross I
bet you still have that Leafs onesie and
I thought you might stick around until
the Leafs win the cup
uh not to be but yes I do still have
that onesie and I'm still hanging in
with them like so many of us across the
country and uh hopeful hoping for the
best again this season
I hated hearing the news that you're
retiring I told you that we're all so
fond of you we rely on you so much so
many people have sent you private
messages here are just a couple from
some of your colleagues
and I'm very lucky to have worked with
you even just for a little bit of my
career
you're an inspiration to so many
journalists across the country Ross our
viewers are really going to miss
traveling along with you to all of those
fascinating corners of Atlantic Canada
thank you so much for your public
service in journalism for close to four
decades I'm honestly excited that you're
finally going to have the time to start
writing your own great story
and what a story Ross 39 years in
journalism The Arc of your career the
things you've witnessed the people
you've met I bet you're reflecting on
that a bit right now
yeah well first of all thank you for
that those kind wishes from
some very kind and talented people and I
I have had time to reflect already and
we'll have more time I hope but mostly
it's a sense of gratitude for being part
of a talented and kind group of people
like you I know you don't like to hear
this but I have to say it extremely
Nimble in thought and indeed and so
yeah it's funny when you think of this
day arriving you're not sure what you
will feel in those moments and I'm
really glad I'm grateful that I feel
gratitude and that that's my
overwhelming sense today
well Ross you have devoted so much of
yourself and your energy to us and we're
so thankful for that so grateful for
your dedication and all the best in the
years ahead to both you and your family
thank you you too thanks Ross
that is global national for this Tuesday
I'm Donna Friesen and it just seemed
right that our your candidate tonight is
the man himself Ross Lord a stellar
reporter and Storyteller and a genuine
good guy
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
thank you